nine months ago a full month after the
presidential election joe biden assured
the american people that he did not
support the federal vaccine mandate for
covid19 mandatory no i don't
think demand to be mandatory but i would
do everything in my power just like i
don't think masks have to be made
mandatory nationwide i'll do everything
in my power as
president united states to encourage
people to do the right thing and when
they do it demonstrate that it matters
clear enough but because his word is
completely worthless joe biden did a 180
and is demanding now that 100 million
americans give up their freedom and take
the fouchy algae and he did so in the
most cartoonishly super villainy
language possible
this is not about freedom
or personal choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you so tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers
with 100 or more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
or show a negative test at least once a
week we've been patient
but our patients is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us
this is not about freedom or personal
choice
this is about joe biden's patience
wearing thin
got it
well i've got two words for joe biden
and they're not mr president
i do not presume to speak for the
american people
but speaking just for us here at the
daily wire
we will not comply joe biden can go
pound sand we will pursue every legal
option available to us to ignore this
incoherent and un-american edict from on
high i'm michael nolsas the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from how dare you
comment is the only thing biden has
built back better is the taliban that's
true it's not totally fair though he's
also built back the haqqani network he's
also built back isis he's all these so a
few more things okay just
in the spirit of fairness joe biden's
speech yesterday
was the most vicious divisive speech
i have ever heard from an american
president
about his fellow americans
it began
well you heard a little touch of it
earlier
it began with this idea of joe's
patience wearing thin look he's a
crotchety old man his patience wears
thin he does it he's not his he's not
old slap happy joe like he used to be
and so he he opens up the speech
vilifying americans who for whatever
reason in their prudential judgment
decided that they didn't want to get the
experimental drug for the for the wuhan
cough
many of us are frustrated with the
nearly 80 million americans who are
still not vaccinated
even though the vaccine is safe
effective and free this is a pandemic of
the unvaccinated
and it's caused by the fact that despite
america having unprecedented and
successful vaccination program despite
the fact that for almost five months
free vaccines have been available in 80
000 different locations
we still have nearly 80 million
americans who have failed to get the
shot the unvaccinated
overcrowd our hospitals are overrunning
emergency rooms and intensive care units
leaving no room for someone with a heart
attack or pancreatis or cancer and a
distinct minority of americans supported
by a stink minority of elected officials
are keeping us from turning the corner
we cannot allow these actions
to stand in the way of protecting the
large majority of americans who have
done their part
i want to get back to life as normal
so 80 million americans who who refuse
to take the experimental jab for the
virus that for most people is just a
mild cold
they they are destroying the country
they are the reason people can't get
cancer treatments
not the lockdown you know remember the
lockdown the various lockdowns that
we've been in that actually prevented
people from getting cancer treatments no
it's not that it's the unvaccinated
because this is a pandemic of the
unvaccinated i don't think that joe
biden would have given this speech this
vicious speech
if the number had been 160 million
he wouldn't have done that because then
you would have had half of the country
not having been vaccinated and he
doesn't want to risk that kind of
political capital
castigating half of the country he only
wants to wait until it's a distinct
minority then he can go out and
demagogue
as he licks his finger he puts it in the
area figures out which way the wind is
blowing and his word is worthless so
when he says there won't be a mandate
that's just a lie so he comes out and he
says okay the the unvaccinated they're
awful people they're evil awful terrible
people they're killing the good
vaccinated americans but
the vaccinated americans are not at risk
i know there's a lot of confusion and
misinformation
but the world's leading scientists
confirm
that if you are fully vaccinated your
risk of severe illness from covet 19 is
very low
in fact
based on available data from the summer
only one out of every 160 000 fully
vaccinated americans
was hospitalized for covet per day for
the vast majority of you who've gotten
vaccinated i understand your anger
at those who haven't gotten vaccinated
i understand the anxiety about getting a
breakthrough case
but as the science makes clear
if you're fully vaccinated you're highly
protected from severe illness
even if you get covet 19.
in fact recent data indicates
there is only one confirmed positive
case per 5 000 fully vaccinated
americans per day
you're as safe as possible
help me out here maybe i'm a little bit
slow maybe i just don't understand this
joe biden is saying
that there are a lot of americans who
are angry at the unvaccinated because
they have anxiety that they could get a
breakthrough case and face the serious
complications
of coronavirus
and he understands that anger frankly
he's stoking that anger in this speech
but
the vaccinated americans are at
statistically no risk of coronavirus
from the unvaccinated americans
right he's saying the science is clear
you're not at risk it's over you have an
infinitesimally small chance of
getting a breakthrough case and of
certainly of suffering any serious
consequences from it so then how why do
you understand the anger why do you
understand the frustration they
shouldn't be angry and they shouldn't be
frustrated because they're not at risk
because the people who don't want to
take the fauchiachi for whatever reason
maybe because you schmucks have been
lying to us for the past year and a half
maybe maybe
they have a
a justification for that
maybe they've got some prudential
judgment
and as you admit they don't pose any
threat to the vaccinated people
but he continues to demagogue
anyway because they listen they don't
pose any threat at all but because of
the massive threat they pose we're going
to make a hundred million people take
the shot
and
i know this is crazy look i'm not an
epidemiologist
but why is the focus
entirely on a vaccine when we're when
we're being told that the vaccines
they do work they're so wonderful
they're the greatest vaccines ever but
also they don't really work and they
don't really stop the spread and you you
need a booster two months after you get
your original series of vaccines but
they're really really good but they're
also not that effective so
if there's so many questions about the
vaccines why not focus on
treatments
we're increasing the availability of new
medicines recommended by real doctors
not conspiracy conspiracy theorists
the monoclonal on antibody treatments
have been shown to reduce the risk of
hospitalization up to 70 percent for
unvaccinated people at risk of
developing severe severe disease
we've already distributed 1.4 million
courses of these treatments to save
lives
and reduce the strain on hospitals
hold on a second so what you're telling
me is that there are all these questions
about the vaccines and it took a long
time to
to jump through all of the various hoops
and they're not quite as effective as
everyone told us they are and that's why
you need new booster shots and there's
still these breakthrough cases and
they're still being transmitted
and you've got a hundred and
170 to 200 million americans who have
taken that
versus 1.7 million
americans who have received the
the treatment the therapeutics that
reduce the risk by 70
that are very effective that you're now
calling calling on them to be more
widespread
why haven't you put any focus on the
treatments before why are you focused
only on this vaccine that has a lot of
questions about it when you could just
focus on the therapeutics which seems
much more reliable
and then instead of having to
jab
shoot up every single american shut down
the economy you could just treat people
who actually have symptoms who are
actually at risk why not do that fauci
fauci has undertaken the strategy from
the beginning of his career this was a
big issue when he was dealing with aids
back in the 1980s
everybody said hey
just develop some treatments he said no
we've got to focus on the vaccine he put
most of the resources behind the vaccine
we still don't have an aids vaccine and
the only way people with aids survive is
because they take cocktails of
therapeutics
decade and decade and decade of failure
and now this guy these people are going
to lie to us they're going to vilify all
of these americans and they're going to
upend
our constitutional order disgust one of
the most disgusting speeches i've ever
seen from a president really makes you
want to protect yourself and your family
and when you want to do that i would
strongly recommend ring ring alarm you
can protect your home anytime from
anywhere i love it especially when i'm
on the road i go on the road a fair bit
and sweet little lace and cute little
junior in our house well i like to know
that we can keep an eye on every square
inch of our house we can know who shows
up at the door before we open that door
we can just it's all centralized all
very simple with ring alarm it's so easy
to install even i can do it incredibly
inexpensive it makes a great
housewarming gift too
because you'll get credit for a really
great gift and you won't have to shell
out a ton of money go check it out today
protect your home anytime from anywhere
with ring alarm go to
ring.com knowles for a special offer on
a ring alarm security kit today build
the system that's right for your home
have it up and running in minutes that
is ring.com knowles
be like me i'm looking at it right now
for another relative of mine ring.com
knowles
mark my words
right now
in a sterile apartment somewhere off of
dupont circle in washington dc
there is a bulwark staff writer who is
furiously pending the conservative case
for
federal vaccine mandates for virtually
every american
through various administrative agencies
i i'm telling you right now there for i
think of the bulwark or some of these
other
fake right-wing outlets they're they're
court jester conservative outlets
they're outlets where they say i'm a
conservative but i only vote for
democrats and i support the liberal
order right there their whole
purpose is to feign opposition and in so
doing legitimize the dominant liberal
ruling class you're gonna hear it
here's the actually
actually here's why joe biden's speech
vilifying
100 million americans and uh
forcing these new penalties from the
federal government on all of these
businesses through the various this is
why it's really conservative
really really conservative
now
because you're going to hear this
nonsense and because biden is going to
push for this
i think it's very important that we be
specific on what our problem is here
okay most conservatives that i see right
now
are saying
i'm not against vaccines i'm just
against vaccine mandates
and i understand why people are saying
that
my view is sort of the opposite though
i'm not against
vaccine mandates in principle i am
against this vaccine specifically
mandating this vaccine i am against it's
kind of the opposite of what the
conservatives are saying but
but my view is right
so
the reason for this is
if you make the argument
that we we have total bodily autonomy
and you have no right to shoot me up
with any sort of inoculation
and that's deeply unconstitutional and
it violates all all of the american
tradition of my god-given rights you're
not going to be able to make that case
very well
because for 116 years now
the supreme court has held
that
actually in some cases the government
can mandate vaccines
there's a case from jacobson versus
massachusetts
1905 held that not the federal
government not osha not these
bureaucratic agencies but the states do
have the authority to mandate vaccines
in certain cases
in that case in particular they were
talking about smallpox
george washington actually goes back
further than 1905 george washington
in 1777
mandated inoculations for his troops
and they were much more dangerous back
then by the way than they are today
but he did it to keep them in fighting
form
that also was against smallpox
if we try to make the argument that it's
deeply unamerican to mandate vaccines
we're going to fail because it we've had
vaccine mandates going back to george
washington
just at some level whether it's just to
the army whether it is at the state
level
i think where we will be successful is
if we make the particular argument the
particular argument is we've never had a
federal
vaccine mandate
for a hundred million plus americans
we've never had it we've never had it
imposed through the proxy arm of
businesses being enforced by osha and
various federal administrative agencies
we never had that
and
i know i know you're not allowed to say
this but the coronavirus ain't smallpox
okay it's much much much less deadly
it's much much much less serious and it
affects
many fewer people even if you're just
looking at various demographics smallpox
is one of the deadliest epidemics that
has ever existed
so when there's a smallpox outbreak
people have to take that a little bit
more seriously and it affects everybody
whereas coronavirus
is very unlikely to to result in grave
injury or death to young people to
healthy people for older people and for
for unhealthy people it can be more
dangerous okay
i think that what the median or the
average age of a of a covid death is
over 82
okay that this is not the case with
people who face serious complications
from smallpox where what something like
30 of them are blind 30 of blindness
cases came from smallpox back when
smallpox still still existed
it would horribly disfigure people and
it would kill people too
i think we need to make i've been saying
this actually
for a while now as i made the case and
speechless
i think that conservatives get tripped
up when we start making these really
generalized abstract arguments that
don't refer to anything in reality
within practice so you're gonna hear
people say you have no right to stop me
from engaging in some behavior that
might harm me yes we do yes we do the
united states has always claimed that
right we have laws against drugs we have
laws for seat belts we have laws for
against pornography
or we did at least they're still in the
books they're just not enforced we do
have laws against that if you make this
extreme libertarian case you're going to
fail because it's completely a
historical but there's a really strong
case to be made that this virus is just
not that big a threat compared to other
epidemics this drug is just not that
much to be trusted given how hastily it
was developed these people this public
health agency and administration are not
to be trusted because they've lied to us
on occasion and have gotten things wrong
generally
and this federal government is
overreaching here if they want to impose
a mandate maybe for a local or state
government that's one thing but the
federal government through the
bureaucracy that's another thing
entirely
what we're looking at here is not so
simple as a matter of freedom versus
tyranny
freedom and tyranny play into this
question but it's not so simple as all
that
what this is about
is
pardon the expression
a whole new world order okay that's an
expression that was trending yesterday
on twitter and it was trending because
an australian politician accidentally
let the phrase slip
back in place especially with reopening
and people going back to pubs and stuff
because our exposure sites still will
they be put back in place to be listed
once we are reopening because they're
not at the moment
we will be looking at what contact
tracing looks like in the new world
order and yes it will be pubs and clubs
and other things if we have a positive
case there our response may be
differently different if we know that
people are fully vaccinated so we're
working through a number of those
issues but we will have to reflect and
learn
the new world order i thought this was
15 days to slow the spread new world
order
because of the woofloo new world order
is a phrase you may have heard before
the the new world order was a term
popularized by george h w bush in a
couple speeches that are now being
suppressed this was back at the start of
the first iraq war the gulf war
what is at stake
is more
than one small country
it is a big idea
a new world order
where diverse nations
are drawn together in common cause
to achieve the universal aspirations of
mankind peace
and security
freedom
and the rule of law
such is a world worthy of our struggle
and worthy of our children's future we
have before us the opportunity to forge
for ourselves and for future generations
a new world order
a world where the rule of law
not the law of the jungle
governs the conduct of nations
when we are successful and we will be
we have a real chance at this new world
order
an order in which a credible united
nations
can use its peacekeeping role to fulfill
the promise and vision
of the un's founders ah don't i don't
know about that wait the u.n is now
going to just go in and kind of run all
these different countries i don't know
about that so when i heard this
australian politician use the phrase new
world order
i said oh where have i heard i heard
that from george bush let me look up
that speech so i look it up on youtube
and the speech won't come up the clip
won't come up actually what comes up is
some other speeches of george bush and
then
a
a header like a little disclaimer that
says the new world order is a conspiracy
theory and it's not real and it's to
totally ignore this there's nothing to
see here pay no attention to the man
behind the curtain you say wait what
nothing says
the new world order is a conspiracy
quite like burying the clips of the
speech of the new world order and
telling you it doesn't exist right
that's yeah okay
oh and having the largest corporation on
earth do that yeah that
that is my fears okay now i'm
but of course that's what this is i mean
that clip
was from september 11th 1990 and january
16 1991 and bush was talking about the
gulf war and he's saying look what we're
going to do now the cold war is over
we're going to remake the entire world
in america's image and his son would
would pursue this path in the second
iraq war and the war on terror and
abolishing tyranny in the world as he
said in the second inaugural
and it was a bit utopian and a bit
progressive and quite liberal and
but they really meant it they really
said we're there is going to be a world
order and we want to change the world
order and
the effect of the coronavirus lockdowns
without question
is that
without i'm not saying it's some sneaky
cabal you know in the shadows somewhere
with space lasers or anything i'm just
saying
the effect of these lockdowns is to
reorder the way that citizens relate to
their nations and the way that nations
relate to the rest of the world that's
just without question i mean joe biden
proved it last night
by upending the constitutional order and
imposing this mandate
that
one hopes many american businesses will
refuse to go along with
you know
we need to protect our most basic rights
here the most basic right is the right
to life which is why i would strongly
recommend you go check out 40 days for
life abortion is in the news a lot these
days because of this wonderful texas
pro-life law and potentially similar
laws around the country
when the topic comes up as it happens a
lot on social media now and in normal
interactions it helps to have good solid
arguments to refute the lies of the
abortion industry well there's a new
easy book for this it's called what to
say when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion it covers
traditional arguments but also my body
my choice when and how to discuss
politics and abortion forced birth
that's the new thing they're calling it
transgenderism and abortion shout your
abortion a whole lot has changed since
abortion was legalized in 1973 what to
say when equips you with proven
approaches from the front lines of 40
days for life which has helped to
convert 221 abortion workers pretty
amazing stuff
know exactly what to say when and not to
say when abortion comes up balance
converting hearts with winning arguments
go on the offense stay on topic go check
it out right now it's a wonderful
invaluable tool what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion how to change hearts and minds
and convert hearts in a brave new world
love that title free shipping 21 off
signed hardback at 40 days for life dot
com what to say when
there is a campaign
right now
for radical liberation now i know this
is weird this is why i'm i'm telling you
when you hear something about the
vaccine mandate or or any other big
public policy
political correctness is like this
wokeness is like this it's not so simple
as saying
freedom versus tyranny
okay freedom versus censorship or
something because
in many ways
the country is freer quote unquote now
than it was 50 years ago
we're freer to say naughty words we're
freer to sleep with whomever we want
we're less free to have political speech
we're less free to state basic truths
we're less free to control our own
passions and and run our own government
but we are more free in some other in
some very base licentious ways
aoc just showed this she just proved
this campaign of radical liberation she
tweeted out in response to a headline
that says aoc calls women menstruating
people while explaining the female body
she said not just women
trans men and non-binary people can also
menstruate some women also don't
menstruate for many reasons including
surviving cancer that require a
hysterectomy gop mad at this are
protecting the patriarchal idea that
women are most valuable as uterus
holders
you it's strange phrasing
but she's almost right here in that last
part she's almost right it's not you're
not a uterus holder i'm not like a
i'm not like a shoulder holder right i'm
not my my body parts are not my
possessions they're part of me but
that's a i'm splitting hairs i suppose
what aoc is saying if she could speak
english properly is that it's there's a
patriarchal idea that women's greatest
asset is their ability to conceive and
bear children that's obviously true
it's not just true for women it's true
of all people
the most incredible faculty the most
valuable faculty possessed
by human beings period is the ability to
conceive and produce children and
only women can do that
contrary to popular belief
not everyone gets to have children not
every woman gets to have children okay
we dealt with this a little bit
ourselves i've mentioned this on the
show before sweet little elise and i
we're catholic we started right away
after we got married and it just didn't
happen right away a lot of people
struggle with infertility it's very
painful for a lot of people okay there
of course there are other ways to
contribute there are other ways to
flourish and have a good life
but it is simply the case that the
center of human life is
the
conception and
creation of children
and aoc is is devaluing that
she's saying oh who cares who cares
about that
the feminists generally have devalued
this said oh who cares about this
miracle that you can create another
freaking human being and then raise that
person and propagate our species
and be fruitful and multiply who cares
about that when you can go work in the
widget factory
why would you want to
rock the cradle and have the hand that
rocks the cradle rule the world when you
can go do spreadsheets for some guy in a
city or something why would you oh my
gosh what a horrible life that would be
to have a good family oh gosh that'd be
then you couldn't be single and drunk
all the time living in a city doing
spreadsheets
it's insane
it's an insane
view of society but it's the consequence
of a radical liberation that liberates
us
not just from
certain social mores
but from the bonds of nature itself such
that women are no longer women not not
all women are uterus holders as she says
even the moderates are radical on this
stuff merrick garland who is supposed to
be the moderate attorney general he's
the one that mitch mcconnell just
smacked down when he was up for the
supreme court and held open scalia's
seat
garland is now the attorney general he
says that this pro-life law in texas is
clearly unconstitutional
sb-8 bans nearly all abortions in the
state after six weeks of pregnancy
before many women even know they are
pregnant
and months before a pregnancy is viable
it does so even in cases of rape
sexual abuse
or incest
and it further prohibits any effort to
aid the doctors who provide
pre-viability abortions
or the women who seek them
the act is clearly unconstitutional
under long-standing supreme court
precedent
those precedents hold in the words of
planned parenthood versus casey that
quote
regardless of whether exceptions are
made for particular circumstances
a state may not prohibit any woman from
making the ultimate decision to
terminate her pregnancy
before viability
so he's quoting planned parenthood
versus casey which is not only one of
the worst decisions in the history of
the united states but also one of the
stupidest it was written by one of the
stupidest justices justice anthony
kennedy who fancied himself a romantic
poet and in his in his opinion there he
he said that people have a
constitutional right to define their own
concept of existence
aoc basically is what he's saying he's
saying yes you if you're a man you can
imagine that you're a woman or a unicorn
or what because we define our own
concept of existence that's our right
of course you don't have that right i
don't i can i can
define my own concept of existence
as being a
six foot four
300 pound linebacker but if i step onto
the football field things are not going
to go very well if if that is the
view that i'm laboring under okay
you don't have the right to do that you
actually have the obligation to
acknowledge reality we all have that
obligation too garland is a moderate
shows you just how far left
not not just the radicals have gone but
the whole liberal ruling class
think about this uh northam
governor blackface hey he might not be
governor blackface he might have been
governor ku klux klanhood we're not sure
which which one he was wearing governor
northam in virginia just tore down
the
statue of robert e lay
it had stood for 130 years
and he tore it down
there was also a time capsule in there
they're getting rid of the time capsule
they don't know what's in it yet
they're going to open that up later
but now there's going to be a new time
capsule northam says
this monument that's time capsule
reflected virginia in 1890 it's time to
remove both so that our public spaces
better reflect who we are
as a people in 2021
the past 18 months have seen historic
change from the pandemic to protests for
racial justice that led to the removal
of these monuments to a lost cause it is
fitting that we replace the old capsule
with the new one that tells that story
so right now everything's got to change
it's not just that we create new time
capsules of where we are now we've got
to get rid of all the old ones
we've got to knock everything down we've
got to just be exactly who we are right
now we don't have any connection to
tradition the new time capsule will be
filled with dozens of new items
black lives matter sticker cdc vax card
a photo of the virginia state police at
the
january sixth insurrection the january
6th an expired covid19 vaccine vial an
lgbt pride pin prayer beads from a woman
who died of covid prayer i don't know
what kind of what they mean by prayer
beads they mean rosary it doesn't sound
like who knows
a collection of poems from middle school
students about kovid
an election officer's badge from 2020
yikes and a video from an interfaith
healing and unity event
does any of that represent you
does any of that represent you
no it doesn't represent me
the gener the generic the closest would
be the prayer beads i guess the generic
prairies to the interfaith healing no
what
that is a radical radical shift and it's
all focused in this very vindictive way
on
how awful the conservatives are they
storm the capital the covid the greatest
threat gotta change our constitutional
or lgbt
pride blm this that and the other thing
it's funny they they have
two different items to commemorate
alleged insurrectionists right one is
blm they're saying we support these
insurrectionists and one is that picture
of the cops and they're saying we oppose
those awful insurrectionists that stole
pelosi's lectern or whatever does that
represent you doesn't represent me it's
an unrecognizable
unrecognizable country
which we don't need to look in a in a
cap for that we can see that
in
in the speech yesterday from joe biden
unrecognizable stuff
as i'm sure you're well aware
just want to put not to find a point on
it
joe biden is using the federal agency
osha to force all companies with over
100 employees to either mandate vaccines
or test their employees for covenant at
least once a week
uh this is an insane out overreach so in
case you weren't listening at the top of
the show we are going to fight that with
every single resource at our disposal uh
we appreciate all of your help joining
us as daily wire members if you join
right now you will be giving us the
resources we need to take this all the
way to the supreme court if that's
necessary dailywire.com subscribe use
code do not comply at checkout for 25
off
we've been far too willing to cede our
way of life to these bureaucrats in the
name of public health
so enough is enough uh please stand with
us we appreciate it uh we are uh
hoping that we can make a stand not just
for our company not just for other
companies but for the american citizens
generally this weekend we remember the
men and women who lost their lives 20
years ago in the most brutal terror
attack america's ever seen in an
extremely important episode of ben
shapiro's sunday special he sits down
with one of the politicians that
shouldered much of the burden that was
placed on the bush administration in the
aftermath that would be secretary of
state condoleezza rice
she was a really terrific guest so if
you haven't had a chance
check it out right now go to
dailywire.com you get it on the daily
wire app apple tv roku or ben's youtube
channel and don't forget daily wire
members get special access to bonus
content from these sunday special
episodes so do not miss it join daily
wire today we'll be right back with a
lot more
welcome back to the show
my favorite time of the week right now
is the mailbag you know before we get to
the mailbag though i do have to thank
everybody because i'd mention this on
the show that i was very honored to
write the introduction to the new 70th
anniversary edition of god and man at
yale by william f buckley jr this is the
book that is widely credited with
starting the conservative movement and
it's available now it's shipping so i
really appreciate everyone who's bought
it i know a lot of you have written in
and if you want to get it you can get it
wherever books are sold it's god and man
at yale by william f buckley jr and you
can read a few pages of my writing i see
i did a book with no words then i did a
book with a lot of words now i'm doing a
book with still not that many words but
but bill buckley wrote the rest of the
word so that's very good first question
up from kirsten
michael i had a couple questions for you
you've talked about learning about other
religions so i wondered if you'd ever
considered or would consider reading or
studying the book of mormon my second
question you often quote chesterton but
which gestation do you quote gk or ak i
don't know much about either of them but
you seem to speak highly of whichever it
is you quote so it got me wondering
thank you for all that you do oh thank
you very much uh you know i haven't
delved deeply into mormonism i have uh
i'm friends with mormons and i have read
some of the book of mormon
um
you know
especially when i was reverting to the
church and you know considering all
these things i did read a lot of
protestants i read some mormonism
actually when i was a kid i had read a
good bit of islam
you know i'd read the quran when i think
it was 14.
mostly because the libs kept telling me
that this was the religion of peace you
know and i just didn't i wanted to read
it for myself i just didn't believe them
healthy skepticism is always good um so
yeah so obviously you know i was not not
persuaded by uh by the book of mormon
and i ended up you know
becoming a returning to be a mackerel
snapping papist um but uh you know once
it's always good to uh investigate these
things for oneself and and to figure out
what you find to be most uh most
persuasive
as for the chestertons i'm referring to
gk chesterton
actually didn't know anything about the
other chesterton until yesterday ak
chesterton who was a cousin of his or
something was a a british fascist
politician and uh so i'm not not
referring to him referring to gk who is
just a magnificent writer of the 20th
century
when was he born he was born in the 19th
century anyway he's just a wonderful
wonderful writer
from aubry hello my swarthy host
hello aubrey how are you
i was out on the town recently and met
some new people who were really fun and
yes some were men i wasn't out on the
prowl but it's always an option when
you're young and single however i tend
to dress slightly more conservative than
other girls and they tend to get more
immediate attention from guys because
let's face it
men are easily distracted
now i'm not dressing like a nun but
sometimes i'm a little more subtle about
accentuating my assets you feel
i feel i feel but i think that immediate
attention can lead to conversations and
sometimes turn into a more long-term
interest as a man of decent values who
isn't blind should i dress a little more
provocative to get more initial
attention and then show them my dazzling
personality
sincerely a lady in the streets
you should
dress to look beautiful
okay and so i'm not saying you should
put a you know
a burqa on
okay i'm not saying you should throw a
potato sack over yourself no you should
certainly show off your beautiful
qualities not just
uh
emotional but also physical
but that doesn't mean that you should
dress like a trollop my dear
you know
i'm hearkening back to my single days
when i'd go go meet the ladies around
town and yes it's true if a gal is
wearing you know dental floss it will
catch your attention but you will form
an opinion about that and very likely
your you will not look at that woman as
though this is going to be the mother of
my children it can happen but it's not
usual
whereas if you see a gal who is wearing
a potato sack yes you should you might
not pay attention to her but but if you
see a woman who is
not dressed like a
gal of ill repute but who is still
beautiful is showing off her beauty in a
way that is
reasonable i think that's the course you
want to go on our society sets up a ton
of false dichotomies we were talking
about the false dichotomy earlier
between freedom and tyranny or whatever
liberty and censorship
we also have this false dichotomy of you
know you've either got to dress like a
street walker or you've got to
you know hide yourself in a burqa but
there there's a middle ground you can
you can acknowledge beauty and even
accentuate beauty without having it be
tawdry
hope that helps
ashton hello michael following the texas
abortion law my social media feed has
been full of despair and disgust
for example i read a post comparing a
fetus to a tapeworm what shocks me
are these pro-choice individuals are
parents themselves
why do you think there are so many
parents out there who are pro-choice
i would think most of them would be
pro-life and this saddens me
i'm married but no children yet but
these crazy nutty lefties have changed
my mind to be more pro-life than
pro-choice
i think a lot of what it comes from
is is
arrogance and
bigotry
basically
what a lot of these women are saying is
and so you know often i've heard this a
lot from liberal white women as they'll
say look i would never get an abortion
i would never kill my precious babies
but poor black women yeah they should do
it
yeah yeah that's fine if poor black
women in like bad cities who don't make
a lot of money oh yeah they should kill
all those but who wants those babies but
i'm just saying for me
i would never kill my baby
right that's that's one
line i've heard
and then the other line which i think
it's important to mention i haven't
mentioned this
yet in this iteration of the abortion
debate
but an important
aspect here too is
sometimes they know not what they do
okay there are i know
i know multiple women who have had
abortions
i know some women who have had multiple
abortions
and
some of them came to regret it deeply
and some of them
are not even really aware of it and they
don't they can't put two and two
together
that's the way this fallen world works
you know for a long time when i was a
teenager i i argued in favor of abortion
i mean everyone i don't think i knew a
pro-life person
it was just it was so obvious oh these
pro-lifers are trying to control women's
bodies and it's not a big deal it's not
really a baby it's like just a blob of
whatever and you know whatever if you
don't
look into it more deeply
you might just stay there i mean the
whole culture is telling you that so i
do think there is
some degree of just
honest ignorance
or
or an attempt to evade
learning more because
it will show you a ghastly reality but
that that's true and so if you know
for a woman who has had an abortion it
can be a very traumatic experience to
realize later on what that means what it
what it was like and and so i think it's
one has to have compassion for these
people too you know i mean you can go
and have your sins forgiven
uh
but but you do have to recognize that it
was wrong you do have to and that's a
very hard repentance is a very hard
thing because it means repentance
literally means changing your mind right
it means actually
turning around changing the way that
you're you're seeing things and that can
be very very disorienting to people from
emma hi michael i'm a college student at
appalachian state university the school
administration is pursuing for the
student body to get vaccinated
as you can probably guess i do not
believe in being forced to receive the
vaccine being 25 years old covid doesn't
pose much better threat to me all the
elderly people are able to receive it
exactly the vaccination rate here is
more than 50 for students and over 80
for faculty and staff but i know that
they're going to make my life more
difficult it's already difficult for me
to wear a mask with my autism
good point i don't want to roll
uh give in and violate my principles my
mom said i wouldn't be rolling over and
giving up what i believe in it would be
me
being forced into doing it what do you
think sincerely my body not quite my
choice i'm really glad you brought up
the autism aspect here because
people refuse to acknowledge
that the masks create problems for some
people the masks create problems for
some people with breathing problems for
instance the masks can create problems
for people with autism because they it's
much much harder to read facial cues i
mean
you can't just
tell the entire population hey totally
upend your way of life muzzle yourself
put this filthy cloth over your face all
the time and it'll be totally normal and
fine and there's no big deal and there's
no problem with that of course there
will be and then you add on top of this
the vaccine mandates
what i would do if i were you and i've
said this before i don't think that
taking this vaccine or not taking this
vaccine is necessarily
you know the the orbiter of of one's
deep most deeply held beliefs
it might be an expression of deeply held
beliefs and i think the fact that the
public health bureaucracy is so callous
and so vindictive and so stupid and so
dishonest
is very good reason
to not trust them on the vaccine
and i don't think that the biden vaccine
mandate is legit
even though i'm not opposed to it in
principle so what i would do is what
we're doing here at the daily wire
i would do everything you can
to avoid it
i'm sure there are ways to avoid it
okay
[Music]
if they do you know hold you down and
tie you down and jab the thing i don't
think it's you know the end of your life
i think uh you know life life will go on
it'll be a horrible uh
infringement but life will go on but i i
i would not be willing to give up just
yet
on this sort of thing
write in to me again if they tell me you
know you're either
you're either taking the shot or you're
out of our school or that you know right
into me again we'll talk then but but i
think they're bluffing in many ways
i think joe biden is bluffing in many
ways i don't think they're really going
to be able to enforce this
i think he's trying to distract from his
failures on afghanistan i think he's
trying to distract from his failures on
the economy
on immigration frankly even a
coronavirus
who's trying to have a shiny object over
here
rile up the provax people to vile up
rile up his base
but i wouldn't i wouldn't fold yet i
wouldn't i wouldn't fold yet i think i
think they're bluffing from ben hello
michael my home state of virginia took
down the giant statue of robert e lee
yes that's true i saw that
i have mixed feelings on one hand the
precedent scares me whose statue is next
and a lot of people consider it a racing
history on the other hand lee did wage a
war against the united states and
committed treason so shouldn't i
celebrate the st so shouldn't i
celebrate the statue of a trader coming
down what are your thoughts on the
situation thanks love the show
oh would that it were so simple i wish
that it was so simple to say he's a
traitor he's bad get rid of him
the american civil war
was a very complex
engagement that had been
boiling up from the very founding of the
country since before the founding of the
country and
politicians tried for decades to stave
it off there were many complex factors
that went into it
and then the union won
and
lincoln declared with malice toward none
with charity for all we're going to come
back we're not just going to invade and
conquer you and and you know slay all
the men and rape all the women and and
raise all your crops and burn your
fields they said we're going to come
back together
and
actually live together all as americans
confederate soldiers are treated as
american veterans
okay for this reason
because we need to come back because
we're gonna have a country are we gonna
have a country or not
is the country gonna be the whole
country or is it are we going to excise
half of the country
so i think it's uh
and by the way robert e lee was one of
the most important figures in bringing
the country back together
it's not like he waged a guerrilla it's
not the taliban he didn't go wage a
guerilla campaign then for years and
years after the war was over
he
surrendered and and helped to unify the
country so i i think the disrespected
him
it well one it's it won't just stop at
him it's already not they're tearing
down washington and jefferson and
lincoln for that matter uh but but i
think it's wrong even in particular i i
do not think robert e lee deserves to be
taken down i think he's actually one of
the more important figures in helping
the country to recover from colby
dear mr knowles i'm getting married this
month we're going on our honeymoon to
nashville tennessee nice but we're
having a hard time nailing down some
things to do besides going to candace's
show and visiting a couple historical
museums what do you recommend
ps what medium strength cigar do you
recommend love the show and as always
your thoughts and insight keep me
speechless thanks oh what do i recommend
well
you know there's a full-scale replica of
the parthenon here with a full statue of
athena it's like very weird it's very
weird but you know you could go check
that out i would go check out some of
the plantations actually speaking of the
civil war some of those are pretty cool
great civil war battle sites down in
franklin not sure if your wife is
totally into that franklin itself is
this gorgeous little town that's very it
could be very romantic i'll have a glass
of wine on a porch somewhere
you can go check out gosh oh go hit up a
cigar boy there's actually a lot of
cigar bars here and a good medium body
cigar
i would recommend especially for the
price point i'd recommend my father
stuff my father makes is really good and
since you're married now you potentially
will become a father very soon
all right
appreciate everybody it's been a very
trying week i know for everybody around
here we appreciate your support we will
keep you posted on our refusal to go
along with joe biden's stupid plan
um if you want to join up right now help
us out you can do that head on over to
dailywire.com appreciate everyone who's
gotten
the new edition of god and man at yale
and i appreciate all of you things are
going to get very very intense
especially as the 2022 elections come on
i think that's what a lot of this
mandate is about i think that's what a
lot of this power grab is about you're
going to see it not just on the public
health stuff you're going to see it on
the election integrity bills
hold firm
stay strong keep the faith i'm michael
knowles the michael knowles show see you
on monday
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
borin our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadofsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by nika geneva the
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021 hey
everybody this is andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin